hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep I'm your host grace Helbig
a very exciting episode we have Ian
Hecox back from Smosh he was here last
time with Anthony this time he is not
here with Anthony instead he's joined by
Courtney Miller also of the Smosh family
and this is just a lovely chill episode
we talked about how they're handling
quarantine obviously the question on
everyone's minds we talked about Ian's
impression and Courtney's impression of
her first audition first mosh we also
talked about the worst video they've
ever posted as a company and as
individual people it was a lot I've seen
the video and it hit a hit a la spots in
a lot of emotional places and we we hear
all about it from their perspective
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
Ian Hecox and Courtney Miller okay thank
you guys for being here for doing this I
want to do my due diligence and just ask
first of all how are you guys doing I'd
say I'd say relatively good although I
found it this this desk is like pretty
indestructible because I I have had a
few moments where I've been like ah and
I like you know it's lamb these hydro
flats are very durable as well so you
throw in little little little teeny tiny
tantrums okay yeah I mean it's good to
take a second and realize what in your
house is unbreakable oh yeah yeah I'm a
responsible tantrum person I don't I
don't go and break something that I'm
gonna regret yeah okay
I'll be very very careful with with any
sort of violent outbursts that I have
I'm like no I'm gonna like throw up
pillow into a couch yeah yeah house any
damage I haven't any violent outbursts
but definitely done
stamp my foot or as ian has experienced
firsthand I I just cry dude
oh yeah ups and downs for sure and like
just like I was in full Damron this one
character we do for his get order
basically dressed like a 15 year old boy
yeah buddy yeah lil Heidi and I just
wrap just crying I can't [ __ ] do this
right now this where yes go ahead
oh my god I was like crying like texting
in and then he actually called me and
you talked you off the ledge dressed as
a character character work is hard in
quarantine I'll the thing to of it I'm
fascinated by with you guys is because
your you're such a group a squad of the
business system a group of friends and
you go to an office every day and you
work together every way every day that
there must be some like strange longing
I mean like zoom calls can only you know
do so much for the human interaction of
it all
yeah I mean we were we were attached at
the hip all of us for the previous month
because we we were on tour and then we
were filming and then we were in
Australia like on another continent
literally with each other the entire
time went from that to just complete
like solitude yes yes I know I there was
a moment in time because I saw that you
guys were all in Australia where I was
like they're not gonna be able to come
back from Australia yeah a lot of people
started freaking out not like like
people abroad started freaking out that
they were gonna close borders because
while we were in Australia they closed
some borders with Europe we're like are
we next
so our flight to Australia was was
basically empty pretty much it was like
pandemic was starting but it wasn't
really West and then while we were there
then things started getting more serious
we were we were in the same city that
that Tom Hanks got the virus when we got
when whoa you had you had Tom and Rita
so you had a known case in the city
known case yeah and we didn't rush we
didn't we didn't schedule an earlier
flight back we just you know it wasn't
that fast yeah when we got to the
airport though it was packed there's so
many people are trying to get back home
before they thought they might close
borders so our flight back was super
packed and I was like well I'm probably
gonna get the virus I just I just
assumed it was a given like sure and
then when we landed in LAX I was really
pissed yeah there is no guy they didn't
have anyone telling people to distance
themselves there's no sort of orderly
thing of telling people what to do they
just like I think five planes lit out at
the same time there was there was maybe
I don't 800 people and that customs line
a giant panic attack for me yeah so just
like probably got it and that after
meeting like 700 around fans in
Australia like it's a miracle I didn't
feel a single symptom and still have it
have you guys been did anyone do the
test at all we just we just hardcore
quarantined and like the moment like the
moment we got back from the airport it
was just like oh well this it begins now
and I may and then shortly after that
then they did like the mandatory stay at
home order so I haven't seen I haven't
seen the office and my yeah do you guys
know if the office is okay yeah we saw
people we saw people that that go in
there and take over the place but it's
like
I don't know it's protected in some
remote they dug a moat around the whole
thing
Oh getting out you have some vigilantes
just guarding the situation for you yeah
these yeah I have you guys good I've
seen I mean you guys have done kudos to
you a really great job adapting to all
of this right now
because I think it could be really easy
for all of you guys to go oK we've all
been together so we all either have it
or we all don't have it so we can all
kind of still be together but you guys
have been abiding by the guidelines
which is great and responsible how's it
been trying to make content and like
shift and pivot how you're doing it from
quarantine its I mean we're fortunate
enough to have a really really talented
team so it's luckily not entirely on us
to figure it out and it's it's been a
challenge but I think we've we've
adapted pretty well and and we have
people that are able to give us the
equipment to shoot it home yeah we we
get sent the equipment I will say like I
feel like it's strong it's definitely a
struggle and our job we have made we've
made the change but my job is so
different from what it normally is or
it's like I'm I'm here now like I I'm
setting up my lighting with the
assistance of brand Brennan over
FaceTime or like right making sure I'm
doing I like I'll forget to turn the mic
on like like we have to do all the crews
stuff right which is frustrating itself
but then also the fact that like I love
our crew our crew is amazing people and
like I don't get to like have their
energy around me and sling mounts also
off of when I'm going to like perform
whether it's a sketch or just I mean
it's different when we're filming
unscripted stuff when we're doing
smiling like we it's us hanging out
together which is great that's right but
yeah like the change is it just sucks
doing it alone you know yeah which can
lead to crying and character breakdown
big ups to the youtubers who just do
this all the time like the solo
youtubers a lot of youtubers like Shane
Dawson they weren't leaving
your house anyway and like they can just
do this and like I I could never be a
solo youtuber I've learned like I can't
do this by myself
I love the ensemble and like having a
team of people whether it's the crew or
just having a cast around me that I can
like emotionally depend on like yeah I
mean I feel like you guys will having a
beautiful reunion once everything lifts
and it'll make you guys appreciate each
other in a deeper level
I'm gonna cry not only be sick of people
I do want to know I want to hear from
both because I like to ask this to
people that come on together I would
love to hear from each side the origin
story of you guys first meeting each
other and if you guys have the same kind
of memory of the meeting oh my gosh sure
to be the audition I mean I would have
been it would have been the audition
yeah yeah I like that it's the audition
yeah because like I'm pretty sure you
guys weren't sure about me that's what
an audition is for you don't know about
anybody like after my audition I'm
pretty sure okay my I had no idea what I
was doing grace I literally that was
like my first official audition ever
ever ow
really yeah they found me from vind in
like Olivia knew me uh-huh
had me send in a comedy reel and I did
one audition like just one-on-one with
the casting director and then the call
this like one was her three in three
auditions yeah no there's just one
callback so I met you so Shane and I
actually had our callback together and
we've talked about it on our pot a
little bit but okay we had our callback
together and I remember walking in and
you guys were there I think I freaked
out more about Joe Bereta being there I
obviously was a Smosh man when I was
younger but like I just wasn't expecting
Joe so my god I used to watch you all
the time and used to used to and I was
basically I was I remember I was like
kind of confused because I was asked to
do the whole audition kind of again
right
like characters and stuff although
that's yeah that's a little
disheartening to be like I just showed
you what I got I do wanna be filmed a
the clip yeah and like I I remember they
asked my favorite movie and I said
guardians of the galaxy and I was
wearing I was throwing up Back to the
Future sleeveless tee yeah nerd we have
so much like nerd pop culture questions
and what was that purpose sort of kind
of like that the personality types yeah
yeah because I mean I think we couldn't
we didn't just want like actors or right
so what here's a question what movie
cook Cortney have said that would have
totally turned you guys off as her
favorite movie if if she just said like
Amelie Amelie is great but you know
people would like to pick that to like
you know right it's like I'm gonna be
this girl I like Amelie yeah gosh I
guess I don't know if she if she said
something like Citizen my only wash
friends friends is the best nothing else
compares friends is the best watched it
eight times so if I was to basic it
would have been yeah that's great she's
the girls not what I'm saying
not that I'm saying the friends bad but
it's good if that was if friends was her
favorite movie I could see that being
I'm letting my I'm letting my my
frustrations of dating apps get gets me
too much because that's like everyone's
bio friends I know so what happened
after you after the audition did you
feel like you got it in the room with
them or did you have to go back and do
that like I have truly no idea what just
happened I had no clue cuz like the
character I did was so weird dude like I
was like I have this character on my
youtube channel that just speaks
nonsense so then I just spoke nonsense
was like oh well if you walk into the
ground you better remember him because
that's the when you flip the switch by
yourself it's not yeah I don't think you
really killed in the audition but out
but but I mean it we thought we saw the
vines we saw that that you were yeah my
comedy reel
yeah potential yeah the audition was
more to just get a feel for like you as
a person and because I mean that's
that's the thing about YouTube and and
online content general well you can't
fake it you're gonna have a group of
people you can't hate each other I think
you can get away with that with
something like Saturday Night Live and
they've proven that time time again
because and some psychos on that on that
show on YouTube like you have to
genuinely enjoy being around each other
and have genuine chemistry yeah so
you're auditioning a friend almost yeah
yeah yeah exactly yeah that's the thing
it's like that's that's why we ask those
questions about like pop culture and
stuff it's like do you have something
that we can relate to right right right
yeah when I walked out I was just like I
remember I was next to Shane I was like
I don't know
how do you think we did and he was
[ __ ] music oh we did great I'm sure
you did fine I was like I've never like
won anything in my life I've like like
so I was just like there's no way this
is gonna happen I was already like at
peace when I got home I was like already
at peace with the fact that it probably
wasn't going to get it
yeah it is truly like winning something
it is a competition auditions are all
competition and Shane did crush the
audition yeah he's impression that's the
only person that I remember truly
crushing the audition but that's because
Shane Shane is like a seasoned actor
like he he knew how to do it wasn't and
it is a real skill I still don't know
how to do auditions I've done one
audition and I sucked so bad
oh yeah what was it for
are you not at liberty to say was it I
want to say it was like I think I think
I think it was for like maybe I think it
might have been like a small role a new
girl or something you go in and you're
like sitting there waiting next to like
other people wait did you actually get
it and forget oh no I think they also I
think they also sent I think they also
sent Anthony in there too so you each
other yeah oh my god it just confirms
that everyone thinks you guys are the
same auditions just to like thicken my
skin cuz like I never did that I never
had to experience that I may want to
cause pain to yourself yeah it is really
it's it's um it's harmful to your psyche
it is a true test of like how much
you're willing to sell yourself and how
much rejection you can actually handle
it's real fun it's real cute yeah
and it's because I don't because it
doesn't really come down to talent
either no there's so many factors that
it's like that's what I continue to tell
myself there's so many other things at
play here that isn't just about like how
you say the words and how you
boat but it's it's you know constantly
demoralizing which is a fun little
roller coaster to be on wait so so
Courtney how many years ago was this
audition a little over five years ago so
you guys have now been working together
for five years yeah that's nice and it
feels like I mean the way that you guys
pose any thing online you feel very much
like a family you feel like a really
like the cast of new girl you feel like
the real group of friends I've actually
seen never seen new girls so maybe that
also didn't help this guy's brothers you
got act like him I'm like dude I'm gonna
do a British accent yeah what so what's
what's office like you know free all of
this what is a smash office environment
really like how would you guys describe
it we recently had we used to have like
a cast room where like we had our own
like office but then we recently moved
us out to be with desks like kind of in
the bullpen with everyone but yeah it
was like slow mornings stuff was
uploading like videos were coming out
and I could come in and get my avocado
toast I dunno I got yeah cool oh yeah
our snack game at the office kitchen
wrong
you can't amazing yeah nobody can nobody
can come up against us with our with our
breakfast and snack game Kroy to thrive
in definitely like mythical was like
this is how we do things because before
it was like if I would like lock their
cabinets with the good snacks inside
like I should have been a sign was it
bait
bagels on Friday something like that
yeah yeah how has the I mean other than
the obvious reasons of like moving from
defied to mythical how is it changed
like for you guys
on a personal level if do you feel like
obviously it's a much better fit things
are going really well yeah I think I
mean we obviously we have to take on
more responsibility for for what we're
doing cuz now like we are in control of
our destiny well we're in defy you know
it was kind of like a fantasy land where
mm-hmm
we were mostly allowed to do whatever we
wanted to do but we weren't really in
control and then it all got ripped out
from under us like like it's like that
like it was so so and then we definitely
like took advantage of their poor
financial choices something yeah right I
mean ya know not to say like yeah I mean
like we we were able to oh you're gonna
like I don't know did some like yeah we
did some like pretty big like projects
and stuff yeah otherwise you're looking
at it now and say well that doesn't make
financial sense but but it's it's great
to like be you know more in control of
our destiny with Smosh and run it more
like a sensible business that's good I
mean also because I mean my impression
of mythical and and rhettandlink is that
they're very they're silly but they're
mature and they're professional is there
a sense of like now you work with them
that you kind of have to like sit
upright and like act professional in a
way there's definitely less napping
around the office is less napping when
they come through they've got such good
energy but you're like oh cause there's
just so freakin tall dude there's no
they're physically so imposing yeah but
I mean I think you describe them
perfectly they are they are very like
sensible like intelligent funny guy
yeah I get very um dad energy around
them of like anytime I'm in their
presence I just want them to feel proud
of me and I don't know why that is but
every time I see them I'm like I want to
do something that impresses you
absolutely like more than my own dad
like I would say like I feel like we
have
I feel more purpose here cuz back at the
old place we it just it felt like I
didn't really know what my future was
outside of what I was already doing
whereas like coz then they kept you in a
box they didn't want to let you to know
how how valuable you were to them and
they didn't want you to feel how much
power you have yeah they didn't want you
to grow too fast so like but with here
like I've been I feel like I have a
future where I'm like oh like I'm
directing sketches and I I'm being
trusted more with creative and like
getting to do more than what I was
originally brought on for like why
addition did that got the job I didn't
even know that I was gonna be flying to
Sacramento to act like and that was all
we were doing was just we were in the
office all the time and then we get sent
to Sacramento every other week to film
sketches and like I was just an actor
that was and then Sloan they're like
okay you can write some stuff and then
eventually got into like the second
channel which was yes so weird that it
was called second channel before yeah
but that's great so it now feels like
you guys actually have some freedom
you're spreading your wings a little bit
and there's like an excitement around
creating in all different forms yeah I
think like also it's it's about
motivation and and finding out what
motivates each person individually
rather than apply a blanket label to
everyone yeah because yeah that was that
was a little bit more of a problem we
found ourselves in under defy was like
no you guys are
like you guys are actors you know let's
let's figure out how to fit you into
these different things and even though
they like I feel more purpose here even
though hi
baby like we are helping young teens
find themselves
guys we have to summer and taking your
shoes off we are helping teens learn how
to grow up and like going on dude but
now even though we don't parade like we
don't talk about that we're just like
kind of making what we like and what we
think is fun and good yeah that seems
like a better system instead of force
feeding you here's the mission statement
yes actually do what you like to do and
the byproduct of this will be that the
audience enjoys it and grows in a
youthful sense okay I want to get into
the personal side of things I want to
find out
Ian how your dating life is going but
we're gonna take a quick break and we'll
be right back with more not too deep did
you know that there's a company that's
mastered the science of sparkle meet
lightbox lab-grown diamonds they hacked
a billion year process to grow stunning
lab-grown diamond stones in about two
weeks and they're some of the
highest-quality stones that exist
they're always near colorless always vs
clarity always a very good cut and
always $800 per carat they come in three
colors to white blush pink and soft blue
after they're grown in the lab they're
transformed into gorgeous lab-grown
diamond jewelry it's Beauty meets brain
go to light box jewelry dot-com slash
Grace and use code grace for $25 off
that's light box jewelry dot-com slash
Grace use code grace for $25 off
and aren't you in love with Courtney's
sister in some capacity yeah well it
seemed like it seemed like it was a
match made in heaven
okay I don't know she just it just
seemed
it just seemed right but no no no no
okay we did a state I think what
happened is I made I made a joke about
it and it bothered Courtney and I'm the
kind of little brother where once I see
something bothers somebody yeah
it's amusing for me so I'm just gonna
keep pushing so when I saw that bothered
her I was like oh this is great
entertainment so I'm just gonna keep I'm
just gonna keep doing this bit that I'm
in love with Courtney's sister okay and
then one day I was on bumble and I was
swiping and her sister came on my app
she showed up she showed up on my app
and and so just you know for the bit I
swiped right oh yeah can you do that can
you send like can you screenshot stuff
on bumble or do you get in trouble for
that yeah you can screenshot Oh cuz I
get screenshot sent to me of people like
pretending to be me all the time
Oh screenshot the random five screenshot
the random famous people that I come
across on there cuz I'm just like dude
with the hood any any of note yeah well
not that I swiped right on any of them
but backdoor Teen Mom Farrah Abraham oh
she's on bumble good for her apparently
and and twice it's now twice Laverne Cox
oh but do you think that's actually
Laverne Cox it's verified verify oh okay
now you're you're right I swipe right on
sister and never got a response be
she has a minimum height requirement on
her Bumble okay I do the bumble profiles
you have to list your height you don't
have to but it's I mean it's basically
like it's almost as important to people
as your gender on dating apps like
height is like height is like such an
important thing for so many people well
it's a thing that people so easily lie
about so what's the point of lying about
you're gonna yeah if you're gonna meet
the person and say yeah I mean I've seen
guys lie about it and then you meet in
person and it's a it's an awkward
situation that's so I feel like those
dummies just figured that everyone lies
about their height so that well but like
you know height is a construct I've
never had the height thing I actually
tried dating a tall guy once not I
didn't try dating one tall guy I was in
high school every other guy I've dated
like they just happened to be like
around my height I don't know but I was
tall I'm not fat I'm not feeling this
reaching up yeah yeah everybody's like
now you guys because you're so close do
do you guys talk about who's dating and
your dating lives and all that personal
stuff with each other a little bit for
me kept mine private because because
jokes get made like dating hoster and
things like that but I in general i I've
I've learned to keep things to myself
more I don't know yeah well this
information well also you guys get very
candid
on podcasts and you know on the channel
about your personal lives and I wonder
and like Ian you've you know had your
girlfriends and ex-girlfriend on
different videos and things like that
yeah do you have boundaries yeah I mean
like I don't
yeah I've shared I've shared details and
I've shared who I've been with online
but I don't I don't like to share like
the day-to-day minutia of my life people
I I've probably been a little more open
since since the start of our podcast but
it's just as far as like sharing
experiences I feel like the fans have
gotten to know you so much because of
the podcast like that's the most they've
gotten of you ever it's it's minimal
editing of you just like your stream of
consciousness like really be like yeah
it must be kind of nice for you guys too
because I know from podcasting for a
while that being able to have a kind of
unedited space to talk authentically is
really nice sometimes yeah and does help
flesh out like your internet character
to everyone else a little bit more um
have you guys is there do you draw the
line on how much you talk about on a
personal level like have you guys made a
conscious decision for yourself of like
I'll talk a little bit but I'll keep
some for myself yeah I tend to like hold
back on like talking about sex stuff
sure because you know how women be
viewed on the internet hmm I never heard
of any problem relating to that I even
tried telling a story on our podcast of
something that happened to me at a party
and like I wanted to go about it like
it's a [ __ ] funny thing I pulled
party culture is so [ __ ]
and weird yeah some dude tried to make
me go to market and you learn you
wouldn't allow it to be funny and it
like hurt me and to this day it like
hurts I'm like dude like we could have
like I'm okay we could have laughed
about this funny
you'd experience like this party these
people I didn't even know it was like a
crazy night and like uh-huh
totally weird that happened I like I
told the guy who invited me the party
that it happened music oh my god I'm so
sorry come to this other party I'll make
it up to you I think I think you're
leaving out a big note what made it so
funny was that you were invited to this
party in a gas station parking lot or
liquor so we were me my cell yeah to a
liquor store near my place we're gonna
grab a couple ciders and just like watch
a movie and this guy in rick acid-washed
jeans was like perfect pops out of an
SUV in his Jordans and is like hey you
guys wanna you guys know party nearby
like it's not this house I'm like and I
I was very curious because I always saw
this big house that always had so many
nice cars this seems like a youtuber
house or like a play yeah I always
wanted to know what went on inside and
so my sister and I were like yeah we
could do this we're fine also that's
such like a movie moment in a gas
station for someone to jump out of an
SUV and be like you want to come to this
part the whole time she's telling the
story I'm just like Courtney no you're
racing like listen you don't know them
yeah that's pissing me I'm triggered
right now I'm in front of you I'm okay
so how about let's laugh about this
funny story last plenty it was a
disapproving dad scenario is there like
trying to like play both sides and like
uh-huh but like one of the top comments
on that podcast video was like Ian so
concerned when in reality like this kind
of stuff happens at parties all the time
like literally every time I've never
accepted a party invite from a complete
stranger in a liquor store parking lot
I'm sorry if it was and you haven't
lived you really haven't lived in you
gotta get out there and experience it
weirdest what's the weirdest party
invite you've accepted grace
oh gosh VidCon yeah that whole that
whole scenario is probably the weirdest
thing but sometimes you just gotta say
yes to those adventures and ridiculous
things happen and they make for great
comedy if you let them make for great
comedy Ian after the fact also teaches
you a lesson
yes I'm a cautious person I already said
a caution oh yeah what's the craziest
party scenario you've ever been a part
of um well it's related to VidCon it was
that really weird did you ever did you
go to but no its rise 9 rise 9 yeah
they had this party it was this I don't
know if it was a real company or what
nobody knew what it was and they threw
this mansion party and you had to have a
golden ticket to get in literally a
mushi douchiest thing ever was this like
one of the first vid cons are like third
or something like that it was maybe like
this it was 20 oh there was one before
it that I feel like what there was some
crazy after party for raywilliamjohnson
maybe it was like that people had to get
weird invites to and you got in like
limos and drove over to this place I did
like a cut it was like a deeper during
that but I remember hearing about it
that was that was maker like yes because
raids signed a maker recently and they
wanted to flex and they feel like they
through him like I think he was the
first one to hit a million subscribers
yeah party they had like a equals three
ice sculptures like this no offense
looks stupid I think you wanted it like
I think in the corner like
yeah but what's this rise 9 so it was it
was the douchiest thing ever so so you
get into a party box to take you to
party they did not explain their like
the parties in a secret location they
did not explain that okay so also when
we said when you wanted to go they
didn't they like put Smosh as the
headline party yeah they put us in some
like advertisement like saying that we
were headlining the party or have to go
we're just going there as as guests so
we can contact but that's the great
party is always talking to your lawyer
first yeah we're very interested to see
what the hell this was so so VidCon is
in Anaheim and I want to say that this
party was in maybe Newport Beach or
something it was like a 45-minute Drive
was a party bus and we get there it's
this giant mansion and we it's because
it's a golden ticket it's kind of like
Willy Wonka themed okay they had and
they had little people dressed up as
Oompa Loompas at the door okay and you
go through and then there's women
dressed as mermaids with like an indoor
pool yeah Wow it's kind of like on
display as well as those women that were
human chandeliers with hot wax just
burning them as they're standing there
to look good like it was a bunch of
internet kids just walking around the
internet kids but also like do she kind
of like entrepreneur type guys you know
did they have like ripped acid-washed
jeans and Jordans Oh probably jeans and
a blazer would be my gasps yeah uh-huh a
lot of those there's a lot of companies
like like try are see what it was like
weed beer like they were they have like
all this weird stuff I feel like maybe
the company was like we are gonna bring
all the biggest youtubers and they're
gonna meet your brands and so like
that's how they got all the money - yeah
- fun party is so weird and then and
then like there was tons of people like
trying to get pictures of me and Anthony
I remember like the cast we all just
kind of like formed a circle around you
away yeah they can sneak pictures of us
they're trying to take pictures of us
like at the party - I guess they just
have camera guys wandering the party I
get video people getting trash and
apparently they had like some big speech
it was the most like I this is like a
party you would see in the show Silicon
Valley it was like it was a joke like
they they got everyone together they
finally had this big speech like we're
gonna change the world with our company
and nobody had any idea what it was I
think what they eventually tried to make
their company was like a Soho House for
youtubers okay yeah like you would pay a
membership and it would be this
exclusive club that you could ya hang
out and I don't know like I'm not I'm
not [ __ ] on like them for for trying
to do something I think that's great but
it's just like a lot of money went into
a party that maybe the money could have
gone somewhere else anywhere else where
was the money coming from the next year
was in this giant warehouse where Aaron
Carter performed with a bunch of cars
everywhere yeah I don't know I missed
all of these for better Wow
I mean really miss anything trust I love
the Internet okay we're gonna take one
last break when we get back we have a
[ __ ] ton of Twitter questions for you
guys so we'll be right back with more
not to date
[Music]
too deep right now is the time that all
of us are struggling with some sort of
stress or anxiety or isolation or
depression and you're not alone we're
all going through it and if you're
curious in something that can help you
out better help better help offers
online licensed professional counselors
who can help their counselors specialize
in issues like depression stress anxiety
relationships sleeping trauma anger
family conflicts lgbtq+ matters grief
self-esteem and more you can connect
with your counselor in a safe and
private online environment anything you
share is confidential you fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your needs
and you get matched with a counselor in
less than 24 hours and from there you
can easily schedule secure video or
phone sessions with your therapists plus
exchange unlimited messages I've had
friends that use this app and love it
it's so much especially because you have
the ability to text with your counselor
everything's super confidential and
super convenient to you wherever you are
however you want to communicate and if
for any reason you're unhappy with your
counselor you can request a new one at
any time for no additional charge it's
an affordable option and you guys will
get 10% off your first month of this
already affordable option with the
discount code grace that's better help
btter h ELP comm / grace discount code
grace talk to a therapist online and get
help ok would you buy a t-shirt for $50
if you knew it only cost 7 dollars to
make I bet you wouldn't I wouldn't and
I'm a betting woman and I bet you would
it and with ever Lane you never have to
overpay for quality clothes they make
premium essentials using the finest
materials without traditional markups
they want you to know what you're paying
for and why so they tell you their real
costs and their radically transparent
about every step in their process from
the materials they use to the ethical
factories that they work with
no matter your style or preference they
have
that look better cost less and last
longer because every lane sells directly
to you their prices are 30 to 50% lower
than traditional retailers that's a
great deal
they have essentials like a cotton crew
t-shirt that's exactly what it should be
versatile simple stylish and made from
quality materials I'm a simple gal and I
like simple nice clothes because I don't
take the best care of my clothes but
with these they're made so well that
they last so much longer than any of the
really cheap e cheap stuff that I
usually go for and right now you can
check out our personalized collection at
everland comm slash grace
we've picked and chosen some really cool
essentials that maybe you vibe with I
don't know I'm using vibe I'm so hip and
trendy and young plus you can get free
shipping on your first order so go to
every Lane evie er LA and EECOM slash
grace to go check out our personalized
collection again every Lane comm slash
grace free shipping on your first order
okay before we get into these Twitter
questions I'm going to ask you the two
questions asked every single yes that's
on the podcast and Ian you've answered
these before when you were on with
Anthony but everyone's answers changed
so the first question is who alive or
dead would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti at this is an answer that can
change you know on a regular basis it's
just who in the moment right now do you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at oh
oh yes okay
the Sackler family who the Sackler
family they're the people that made
oxycontin they chose the market to
doctors to instead of marking to the
people they market to the doctors to get
them to push oxycontin and basically are
responsible for mostly responsible for
the opioid crisis yeah I did see a
documentary on that recently and it's a
private it's a private company it's a
family and they use their money to fund
museums and colleges and all these other
stuff make them look good well they can
go [ __ ] themselves
Wow okay I can say for sure we have not
had that answer yet so thank you for
bringing that into existed
cold spaghetti the people who are
freaking on they're going to the beach
you know yeah get some clarity on you
yeah the especially the people without
masks hit him right in the in the mouth
Hall mm-hmm
I feel like that could help and who
knows maybe eat cold spaghetti is the
Cure in heaven you know we haven't
tested it yet I don't know awesome the
other question I ask every single guest
is to tell us your worst pants [ __ ]
story or close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases or a
combination so mine is college jogging
front lawn okay this is gross okay okay
constipated magnesium citrate aftermath
oh yeah that's that's a medical issue
for sure
date uber traffic Wow
okay let's get into these Twitter
questions someone to know if the
original founders of Smosh were Courtney
and Shane what would their Smosh look
like Oh God would it be called Smosh
like if I got I mean no the way that the
name came about was because of like
friends having like an inside joke right
I don't know what I don't know what you
and Shane would make together like
different ideas of lots of music videos
and you'd be like I want to make like
legit cool like comedy sketches
you guys are make you guys would make
like cool character sketches though
Smosh would be so sexy if I created it
there you go
super set sex appeal would go up a
thousand percent mm-hmm
you guys talked about the the first
auditioning process but what were your
first impressions of each other someone
wants to know Courtney what was your
first impression of Ian when you got to
like actually when you got the job and
started working together I was so taken
aback by how down-to-earth and what a
great like listener he was um just like
a person who he he made me laugh like
with his improv when we were when we
filmed sketches in Sacramento but like
also when we be at the Smosh house
sleeping there after shoots like I
remember having late nights where I
would just like talk to him about like
stuff I would just word vomit my life to
him and just like listen and like just
talk and just be chill like it was very
I was not expecting that at all from
like one of the top youtubers who I was
a fan of when I was in eighth grade
that's cool he's a real human being
yes but truly he's just slowly gathering
ammunition to use against you he has
and he has and what was your impression
of Courtney after you guys started
working together it's okay you can be
mean it's fine no I don't have anything
mean to say I just have really bad
memory I don't know like you you just
had so much raw talent I think that was
I think that was the thing like we like
we saw your vines and everything we knew
that that you are a really funny person
you have a lot of talent and and but you
were but you're agreeing you know you it
was it was raw talent like we needed to
form you in the fires you into the
comedian that you are so yeah I think I
think it was we were just very
optimistic about about you that's cool
someone to know what is your strangest
pet peeve that just makes you instantly
furious well now it's it's people that
are walking by other people without a
mask yeah they could clearly when they
have the room to like give the person
some space like yeah we're a mess and
distance yourself from everyone else
like there's a there's a loop near me
that everyone's like running and walking
on and they just made it one direction
so people aren't passing each other have
to like walk the loop in this one
direction and still there's people that
are ignoring the signs that's literally
like every 10 feet on the trail and
they're walking the opposite direction
or running no mask no distance yeah when
you when you run do you wear a mask I
get in I've been avoiding any streets
with people yeah I I keep a good 10 foot
yeah that's what I've been doing but
yeah otherwise I can't breathe when I'm
running yeah I get really claustrophobic
yeah I think into a mess yeah I exercise
to do
ESMA so it's like I already had but yeah
I know III know I should even when I'm
running wear a mask I'm keen everybody
I'm I will cross it's ok did somebody I
did have like a guy in my neighborhood
like as I was like going by he was like
masked I was like that's fine like like
appreciate you you know for speaking up
I think that's important that's
basically like the equivalent of a
citizen's arrest I don't know it's like
that make me hurt so hard inside because
like I know that I'm being a good person
but just in this one moment if I'm doing
something like slightly off of the
perfect rule book and someone calls me
out for it I want to be like but I'm a
really good person other than this one
moment that you someone to know what is
the worst thing you've eaten for the
sake of a video Oh God so many names a
wet hamburger that was the worst thing I
thought does that mean like we had a
joke in a sketch a long time ago about
like dropping like a whole hamburger
into a bucket of water and then pulling
it out and then and then taking a bite
of it and I was supposed to take a bite
of it going Oh gross because then wat
the bun is like all soggy it's just
against melee and it's falling apart in
your hands like of all the gross things
that I've eaten that's the one that that
really just stands out because nobody
should subject the full dunked wet
burger yeah I think for me it was a the
file up sort of put it in my mouth it
was a smoothie that consisted of ranch
dressing soda a couple of awful cheese's
durian and two other things
that were just they were the worst
things we had ever had on put it in my
mouth and so we made a smoothie and I
literally I my entire body just heart
like I don't know what that what's that
what's that French instruments like
accordion cardian my body was an
accordion and crushed all the food out
of my frigging body that day
that's definitely worse than a than a
wet hamburger hamburger
I would I would eat it I will eat a hit
wet hamburger right now if you ask me
tonight I could send you instructions
dunk in Dasani know what keeps them
inspired during quarantine if that's
possible is it possible to stay inspired
during quarantine I feel like a lot of
my like when we're when we're making
videos together for likes mosh pit just
like the pure energy of like I'm having
fun with my friends is is plenty of fuel
for the fire and then watching other
youtubers honestly like it really it
wakes you up in terms of like when
you've watch people like Danny Gonzales
or like Cody Co those people like are in
a similar vein of comedy kind of in a
way totally yeah keeping a roof over my
head
inspires me to to continue to create
money yeah yeah just just just purely
money I don't know like it's yeah it's
it's very hard like I don't want to
complain about it being too hard it's
like obviously people have it people
have it much worse but yeah cuz you have
to in this in this current iteration
that we're in it's it's so much more
down a personal responsibility its we
you know we're not going to an office to
do our work you're waking up and then
doing work during the day
and you don't have any responsible for
that so it's it's a yeah sometimes that
could be that could be challenging I'm
not gonna say it's hard I can't because
I feel bad because I you know obviously
other people are going through much
worse so sure but also it'll give you
guys I think like a really deeper
appreciation when you are able to get
back in the office and make stuff with
each other again and like go back to a
much more efficient style of content
creation sure take it for granted after
two weeks yeah exactly and then you'll
get right back into the rhythm last
question before we go we give you guys a
gift for being guests on this episode
what is what's the worst episode of
Smosh you ever put out someone wants to
know mm-hmm what's yours what's in your
opinion you know oh I know first I know
what the worst what the worst one is
okay that was the two truths 1 lie
episode that I did with my ex yep I've
seen this and you know what it was the
worst year it's literally the worst it's
the worst content it's the worst content
and we cut out like honestly like I
think I think we should have won an
Oscar for Best Drama was real so what
happened for the viewers that didn't see
this we play this game called - 2 truths
1 lie where you tell three things and
the person has to guess which two things
which two things are choose which one's
the lie and if you if you get it wrong
you get squirted with water my my ex who
was my ex at the time we shot this
that's why we did it we thought it'd be
funny to bring her on already a very
very dangerous territory to be a
boyfriend so it's like it was it was
gonna be fun and I thought it would be
really good good content if for the last
set of of things one of the
your answer lies was was that I cheated
on her and and we like there's one thing
that that we had in our relationship it
was trust and and I did not cheat on her
and so she was like well I know you
didn't cheat on me so it's gotta be this
other thing but in that conversation
there was a lot of weird mental
gymnastics that were happy yeah
gray area yeah there's a lot of like
weird like crosstalk that's happening in
this this part and I thought she said
one thing and uh basically what happened
is I had insinuated that I did cheat on
her and I sprayed her with water so not
only did she think that I cheated on her
at that moment I also sprayed her yep
with a water gun just to add insult to
injury and then like and then everyone
was freaking out because it was it was
Courtney Shane and Damien like watching
right yeah I mean I have to say I have a
huge appreciation to the three of you
for having to physically be there in
that moment and and like keep your
emotions in check while this is playing
out in front of you and Shane acts like
you see his rage in the moment because
he was like didn't just do that to her
[Music]
yeah because I told him I told him that
that that was gonna be the last one I
was gonna throw in there
I don't think so they so well I think
Shane I think so I thought one of them
knew and so then when they when I said
it they're like whoa wait he got it
wrong so they were like what are you
doing what are you doing I was like what
oh [ __ ] oh my god and we had like knock
down the cameras for ourselves and she's
covered in water she was shaking
dude it was it was so bad I felt I felt
terrible garden well I mean it made for
it made for its outwards Dale was agony
no yeah I mean I wasn't gonna say don't
release the video right even though he
left it up to her she she take a look at
the cut it made me look terrible but
it's it's like that's life you make it
six in life I'm not a perfect person in
terms of remembering how rules work you
know those are the moments that do end
up creating boundaries for yourself in
the future of how far you should go for
content yeah but it's resulted in some
pretty funny memes that's good and you
can get a meme out of it it's worth it
of course
Courtney is there anything that comes to
mind for you that is the worst Smosh
content I don't know I feel like it's it
depends on like what the finishing
product looked like but versus the
emotions are what it took to make it so
for me the the roughest thing we ever
had to film was every bird ever and we
joke about like that's the most bad we
video we've ever put out because it's
like every bird ever really to that but
I remember I we were filming in the hot
Sun and I had to wear these like wings
that was basically like one long piece
of fabric that like had little tubes to
fit your arms in and they I don't know
they just didn't have my measurements
but like mine was too small and my
fingers are basically tight packed in
like this and like I had to sit there in
the hot Sun with that with like a bird
thing on and like full bird yeah like
and I remember in Sacramento in the
summer degree or higher
your art you do it for the comedy you
know people liked it or not but the fans
laugh yeah you we did it
we've reached the end of the podcast you
guys thank you so much for being here
I know I could talk to you guys for
another few hours but um before we
completely wrap up we do have some gifts
for you guys usually when we do this in
person we create personalized fortune
cookies for our guests
and so we've been trying to do it
digitally and virtually so i think
melissa has emailed them to you guys if
you're able to see okay and if you guys
open them and you'd like to read your
fortunes out loud please go for it okay
here it is found it
alright who wants to go first I'll go
first okay okay mine says it was a
little cookie cracked open it your long
oppressive run as mayor of Smosh is
almost up your odds of winning
re-election is high but at a cost that
will reveal itself in time that's creepy
here's mine let me open up my cookie kay
mr. peanut and Michelin Man heard you
were a big fan and have started
combining their genes to create your
ultimate sleep paralysis demon this is
exciting but also look what you've
[ __ ] done
scary mascots yeah the old ones combined
together their power knows no bounds mmm
so where can everyone find everything
that you guys are up to because you have
12,000 things going on on the internet
if they don't already know yeah they
could they could start at Smosh on
YouTube they can fan out to Smosh pit or
they could find us on we're doing some
fun tech talks we're doing usually
everything we filter through Instagram
or Twitter at some point on spawn the
Smosh accounts
ian's at ian hecox what else would he be
and then I'm kasha
oh I'm I mean Oh on Twitter I'm smashing
it and I think well I remember nice all
I mean he just looked it's all there
yeah surname use not too many fake
accounts i or you can find on bumble
thank you guys again for being here guys
go check out everything that they're up
to they got merged they got coffee
they got podcasts they got spin water on
each other they got ex-girlfriends
experiencing new trauma there's
something for everyone thank you guys
we'll see you next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye cuba
2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep back not too
deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa D months
edited by Shireen Loni Eunice post
production sound by Chris Henry and an
extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]